Speaker 1: OK. Donald Trump spent
the weekend delivering these febrile,
unhinged interviews to a number of different
media outlets, including Fox News and others.
And some of these are fascinating in that Trump
reveals his retrospective view of his presidency,
and it's bizarre. And we're going to get to that
first and foremost just to kind of like get some,
some business out of the way. Trump asked about
the story that he was flushing documents down the
toilet. He says it's not true and that there's no
way Maggie Haberman, who is breaking that story,
would know if it were. Here's Trump.
Speaker 4: It's a totally false story.
He made it up. I don't believe they have sources
who's going to be a source for that anyway? Who
would know that personal stories they make it?
Speaker 1: White House staff who admit
we were called up to unclog Trump's toilet. It
appeared that what was in there was was paper
documents with with stuff written on it.
Speaker 4: You know, they they oftentimes these
fake writers like her, are they they act like they
know me, like she knows we haven't spoken her in
a very, very long time. You know,
Speaker 1: I think there are criticisms
to be made of Maggie Haberman. One such
criticism would be if she knew for a
while that Trump was power. Flushing documents
down his toilet. You could say she had a duty
to expose that before being able to monetize
it in a book. This is not a criticism unique
to Maggie Haberman. Many of these people hold
the most insane stuff they know for a book
on which they make money. That would be a
criticism. But Maggie Haberman does not have
a track record of making stuff up or making up
sources, which would be an incredibly serious
thing to do as a New York Times reporter,
Speaker 4: as we know better than any
other writer. But they write books like They
Know and then they make things like that up,
and there would be no way of her knowing if
it were the fact there would be no way of
understanding that or knowing it.
Speaker 1: Well, she claims to, and she
has a certainly much more honest track record than
does Donald Trump. So Donald Trump then going from
Fox News over to the USA radio network, where he
was interviewed by Wayne Allen Root Way now and
Root has been a guest on this show many times,
and Wayne Allen Root has been one of the guys
saying If Republicans take the House in
November, make Trump the speaker. Remember,
you don't have to be a member of the House to be
made speaker. They can vote for anybody, and Trump
could be made speaker of the House Way now. And
Root asks Trump, Is this something you would think
about? And here's the wild and wacky answer
Speaker 2: the idea Why can't after we win
back the House, you become speaker of
the House even for a short period just
until we can in the open investigations
against Biden and the Biden crime family?
Speaker 4: Well, I think a lot of things
are happening and a lot of very positive
things are happening. And you know, when you
look into the future and that was your idea,
I heard it from you first. I don't know. It
certainly has been going around. And frankly,
I hope we don't need it because what should
happen is what the plan did. We're on now.
And I think a plan that's going to make people
very, very happy. We'll be announcing sometime
later. And that's really what should happen.
Speaker 1: But now, of course, is he is he
alluding to, we're going to announce that I'm
going to run. We still don't know. We just we
just aren't sure, but everything's always just
around the corner with Donald Trump and certainly
not ruling out the idea of him being speaker of
the House. Now, beyond parody, back to Fox News
about Trump making a very confusing and dishonest
claim about the wall, the infamous wall.
Speaker 4: We were two and a half three weeks
away from think of it finishing the wall,
which is largely frankly finished
anyway. It's a tremendous help. Right?
Speaker 1: We were to do so, so consider that
we were two to three weeks from finishing the
entire wall with the US-Mexico border. That's
untrue. It's a complete and total lie. There is
no wall on the vast majority of the border. They
were not about to finish it. But then, he says,
and quite frankly, it was finished. Well, why
did you need two to three weeks to finish it
if it's finished? And of course, then the real
policy question is if you finished the wall,
why isn't it stopping people from coming over
which Trump claims are coming over in record
numbers under Joe Biden? If the wall is there,
how is it? How was it working? It's all very,
very strange. Now here is the wacky. This is the
most delusional part of the entire interview.
Trump describes his presidency as being
a glamorous time in American history
and a romantic period. He imagines his
presidency was like an episode of Downton Abbey.
Speaker 4: Just the numbers. Our country was
thriving. We were just beating everybody.
And by the way, George in China, massive
taxes and tariffs taking in hundreds of
billions of dollars. We never took in, guys.
Speaker 1: He's he still doesn't understand
how tariffs work. You guys know this, right? Like
when Trump says we were charging China tariffs and
taking in money from China, that's not the way
it works. The tariffs are paid by the American
companies importing the Chinese goods. Five need
steel to build an American company, and you put
a tariff on Chinese steel. I pay China for the
Steel, the Chinese company for the Steel. And then
I pay a tariff to the U.S. government. It's the
American companies that pay the tariffs. He still
doesn't appear to get it. OK, but let's continue.
Speaker 4: Ten cents, and they viewed it as a
romantic period, I think. And I think that's
really why it's doing so well because there
is a lot of romance to the book. It
was despite all of the vicious hoaxes
and scams that they pulled and made up stories
like Russia, Russia, Russia. You know, you had
the Mueller, you had impeachment, hoax number one,
impeachment of number two. Despite all of that,
they view it as a very glamorous time
because our country was doing so well.
Speaker 1: This this is so I get that it Trump
is like, you know, seeing himself as some kind of
Elizabethan leader during a romantic. It's
all bizarre, and it's it's empirically untrue.
The reputation of the U.S. under Trump was I know
that with Trump, it's this is can be literal. It
was in the toilet. You know, he had Ted Nugent
in the Oval Office. Not exactly the pinnacle
of glamor or romanticism, but of course, the U.S.
was widely seen as the global laughingstock under
Trump. OK, one last clip from this unhinged series
of interviews Trump rounding out his media tour
this weekend by spreading mask disinformation,
Speaker 4: and everybody says that the mask for
the new variant at least is virtually ineffective.
I mean, totally ineffective. So I don't know what
they're doing and why they're doing it, but
they've come out and said that the mask has
almost no impact, especially on the new variant.
Speaker 1: And now that's of course, untrue. What
we have found out is that due to how contagious
are Macron is, you really want to be wearing a
properly fitted N95 k N95. I think there's the K f
ninety four. You know, you want a properly fitting
good mask wearing one of those gators or as I once
saw a woman do on a plane, cover her face with a
paper towel to walk to the bathroom. Or you don't
want to be doing that. You want to be wearing a
proper actual protective mask. So really very
dangerous and weaponized disinformation being
spread by Trump, but fundamentally still repeating
all of the same lies he's been repeating. And
there's there's a whole network of places
where he's allowed to do it. He goes on
and he goes on. Newsmax, Fox News the way now
in root, wherever he's accepting interviews.
Other than that recent NPR interview, where he
was actually confronted and hung up the phone,
he is welcomed and allowed it to spread all
of this stuff. And that should really concern
all of us because there is still a very willing
audience extraordinarily receptive to the lies